i mean this is a good point in terms of
uh
general flu intelligence to mention in
your paper you describe different kinds
of generalizations
uh local broad extreme and there's a
kind of a hierarchy that you form
so when we say generalizations
what what are we talking about what
kinds are there
right so uh generalization is very old
id i mean
it's even older than machine learning in
the context of machine learning you say
a system generalizes if it can uh
make sense of an input it has it has not
yet seen
and that's what i would call a
system-centric
generalization you is generalization uh
with respect to novelty
uh for the specific system you're
considering so i think a good test of
intelligence should actually
uh deal with uh developer wear
generalization which is slightly
stronger
than system-centric transition so
developer generalization developer aware
generalization would be
uh the ability to generalize to novelty
or uncertainty that
not only the system itself has not
accessed to but the developer of the
system
could not have access to either that's a
fascinating that's a fascinating meta
definition
so like the system as
uh it's it's basically the edge case
thing we're talking about with
autonomous vehicles
yes neither the developer nor the system
know about the edge cases
so it's up to they get the system should
be able to generalize the thing that
that uh nobody expected neither the
designer of the training data
nor obviously the contents of the
training
that's a fascinating definition so you
can see generalization degrees of
generalization as a spectrum
and the lowest level is what machine
learning is trying to do
is the assumption that any new situation
is going to be sampled from a static
distribution
of possible situations and that you
already have a representative sample
of that distribution that's your trying
data and so in machine learning you
generalize to a new sample
from a known distribution and the ways
in which your new sample will be
new or different are ways that are
already understood by the developers of
the system
so you are generalizing to known
unknowns
for one specific task uh what you would
call robustness
you are robust to things like noise
small variations and so on
um for one a fixed
known uh distribution that that you know
through your training data
and a higher degree would be
flexibility in machine intelligence so
flexibility would be
something like an l5 cell driving car or
maybe a robot that can
uh you know pass the the coffee cup test
which is the the notion that you'd be
given a random kitchen
uh somewhere in the country and you
would have to you know
go make a cup of coffee in that kitchen
right so flexibility would be the
ability to deal with
unknown unknowns so things that could
not
uh dimensions survivability that could
not have been possibly foreseen
by the creators of the system within one
specific task
so generalizing to the long tail of
situations
in self-driving for instance would be
flexibility so you have robustness
flexibility and finally you would have
extreme generalization
which is basically flexibility but
instead of just considering one uh
specific domain like driving or domestic
robotics
you're considering an open-ended range
of possible domains so um
a robot would be capable of uh extreme
generalization if
let's say it's designed and trained uh
to
to for cooking for instance um and
if i if i buy the robot and if i'm able
uh if it's able uh to teach itself
gardening
in in a couple weeks it would be capable
of extreme generalization for instance
so the ultimate goal is extreme
generalization yes so be
uh creating a system that is so general
that it could essentially achieve
a human skill parity over
arbitrary tasks and arbitrary domains
with the same level
of you know improvisation and adaptation
power as humans when
when it encounters new situations and it
would do so
uh over basically the same range uh of
possible domains and tasks
uh as humans and using this essentially
the same amount of training experience
of practice as humans would require
that would be human level extreme
generalization
you